- So wait, do you have something
planned with my band today?
I heard that you did,
and I'm very excited.
- Yeah.
You're missing something in the show.
And I think that a theme song,
you don't have a theme song.
- Oh, I don't have a theme, 'cause we--
- We have worked up a
few theme songs for you.
- All right.
Can I hear?
Do you want to tell me about one,
or maybe sing one or I don't know.
- Let's just sing it.
- Let's sing it, okay let's do it.
(audience clapping)
You have now given me permission to
use this as my thing.
I'm just saying. (laughs)
'Cause I love this.
I'm excited.
- Hit it, Jason.
(upbeat music)
♪ It's time ♪
♪ Time to watch some Kelly ♪
♪ Kelly on the telly ♪
♪ It's the Kelly Clarkson show ♪
- You talk about that ending!
All right, all right.
I liked it.
- I felt the vibe, I liked it.
- What do you think?
- I love it.
I have a feeling I'm
gonna want all of them.
- It's for sale.
- I'm gonna literally have,
I want all of them to like
for different people that call
because I feel like you have
a few and I want all of them.